there's pictures of him when he was
younger after 21 years old how many more
inches do you grow after 21 right and he
wears these boots and it just doesn't
look good right so this hashtag for two
days was trending called boot gate after
we did the podcast and I asked him a
question and I gave him a box of
ferag his shoe size I said I'd love to
see you wear dress shoes and tennis
shoes and he says I can't accept a gift
you know why I was doing that I was
doing that for there to be a moment of
levity and self-deprecation for the
audience to be like you know what I like
him let me give him a chance he's a
human like me cuz when Trump went on
Jimmy Fallon he says hey Jimmy Trump
they say your hair is a tupe he said my
hair's not a tupe it's my hair he says
you sure can I touch it he says well I'm
about to go to fundraising at Rhode
Island I just hope the people in Rhode
Island know if my hair is messed up it's
because of Jimmy